how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have some very interesting
and very exciting news it has been
reported that the Marvel character
Hercules is going to be entering the MCU
very soon we're talking as early on as
phase four and for those of you who do
not know much about the Hercules Marvel
character don't worry we'll go into
detail in this video but the most
exciting news is of what movie he could
potentially be appearing in Hercules was
actually rumored not too long ago to be
appearing in the Eternals but Hercules
also has a very long history with Thor
the God of Thunder and it looks like the
two of them could be facing off against
each other and Thor at love and thunder
and we'll talk about it in this video if
you're new be sure to subscribe to enter
my weekly giveaway for a chance to win a
Hulk from Avengers in-game Funko pop
also I'm still partnered with tops to
bring you Marvel collect bye tops I've
been trading with a lot of you and it's
been a lot of fun and if you don't know
what it is it's a super awesome Marvel
card collection game that is on your
phone we all know everything is digital
right now so for those of you who love
collecting cards this is a perfect app
for you you can collect cards by earning
coins to purchase them with and you can
trade with other people online as well
when you log in you can spin the wheel
that gives you either cards or coins to
purchase cards with they have some
awesome cards to collect right now
including Avengers x-men carnage and
right now they currently have a Doctor
Strange pack available which has
characters like Hawkeye quake Hulk and
Professor X all the characters that you
know and love you can collect you can
follow me on Marvel collect bye tops
under the username cosmic Wonder find me
and let's do some trading so the report
comes from cinema spot and it reads as
follows sources have told the cinema
spot that Hercules is coming to the MCU
in the near future it is unclear whether
this would be in the form of a
supporting role or a lead role in his
own project but there were once rumors
that Hercules would appear in Marvel
Studios 'as eternals those rumors have
since been put into doubt and it is more
likely that the casting call in question
was for Icarus who is being played by
Richard Madden now if you don't know
anything about Hercules he is an
Olympian it's basically the Greek
ecology Hercules he said God just like
Thor
and that's why although there are
several movies coming out in phase four
there are really two most likely options
for him to make his MCU debut one is the
Eternals the Eternals are basically gods
themselves and they were made by the
Celestials who are actually gods so
you're going to have a movie that's
about gods and then it's going to cover
the course of over 30,000 years we know
that they're going to explore ancient
Egypt in this and perhaps they could
even explore ancient Greece if they do
this there's a high chance that Hercules
could be in ancient Greece as a god and
we could see the Eternals interacting
with him because they're basically one
of the same but the other option which
could be more likely is that Hercules
could appear in Thor love and thunder
now the reason that this could be more
likely is because Hercules originally
made his first debuts fighting Thor the
two of them would go to battle but
eventually four would end up saving
Hercules from the netherworld who was
controlled by the Olympian God Pluto
from there on out Hercules would go on
aiding Thor and even help him with the
Avengers sometimes now we know that
Christian Bale is going to be playing
the main villain in Thor love and
thunder and perhaps Thor could use some
help he's already going to need the help
of Jane Foster Thor but maybe that's not
enough now it is possible that they
could simply run into Hercules and
Hercules could give them some new
information about maybe Gor the god
butcher or even Dario agar one is a god
butcher so perhaps Hercules the God
could have had contact with him and the
other is a person who was turned into a
Minotaur by the gods these are two very
powerful villains villains that Hercules
could help Thor defeat because of his
knowledge and that's why these two
movies are the most likely but like the
report said there is a chance that he
could get his own project and that might
come in phase 5 the report does say in
the near future so that leads us to
believe phase 4 but phase 5 could just
be right around the corner as well so
let me know what you think about this
new report let me know what you think
about Hercules coming into the MCU and
where would you like to see him debut
would you like to see him in the
Eternals Thor love and thunder or would
you like to see him have his own project
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU for live updates you can follow me
on Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof